we went back we were listening and
Gary's audiobook yeah at one point he
ran out of [ __ ] to say in that book no
he described his office in the book what
was in his office I said Gary why did
you write that in your book he goes I
don't remember writing that in the book
I've got so many great pictures in my
office
there's a frame 10 by 12 shot Howard
gave me as a birthday present showing
all of us from the show dressed up and
dragged at a photo shoot for his second
book Miss America
there's my younger son Lucas doing the
tricky dick Nixon pose on his campaign
poster when he ran for fifth grade class
president that's kind of framed limited
edition edging of Jay Leno sent to me by
Helen Kushnick his old agent who was
played by Kathy Bates of the movie late
shift
don't you hate the way Gary reads the
facts
irritate me I'm so irritated by Gary's
book I tell you somebody sent this to me
and I went I wanted to throw this tape
out the window Helen Kushnick in the
late night well what am I supposed to
write about I can't write about ball
chapter 2 this was everything in my pen
draw this bill was given to me by this
pencil is from Rite Aid and it has an
eraser on it this is a napkin that Evie
Hoffman pulled out of the trust blow his
nose with chapter 3 post-its my
philosophy if it makes it to a post-it
it must be important over here is my
snack door over here is the package of
locks that I'll cook from the guys in
the back chapter 10 here are some things
that are not in my office a treadmill a
toaster the Eiffel Tower alarm clock a
long plug that's right how did you know
although there's some drool on my carpet
from when I took enough and I fell
asleep then my head was all the way back
I almost fell out of my chair Terry what
was your thinking there did you just run
out of [ __ ] to write about I mean do you
really think that's that exciting your
office I have no memory of it I said I
don't blame you I don't know why I put
it in there I don't know if they asked
me to put it in or if it was my idea I
just don't know is your office now
drastically different I know some people
are clamoring for an update can you give
us one
a lot of pictures in here but most of
the stuff described in there is no
longer on the wall would you describe
the stuff on your wall I'm passing in
there's a big a that serious did four
East Street radio why is that up there
cuz I'm a big bruise fan I saw the
picture of all of us a drag
cheerio sent me a box because I'm a big
Cheerios either that's us Baba Booey on
it can I say something
I think you got another book in you now
what happens if Jason comes in and tells
us what's in your office is that allowed
okay oh yeah
today it's a whole different attitude
yeah that's happening I heard you guys
were just arguing again all fear oh
really
I'm just very sensitive lately are you
all really sensitive lately Gary I don't
think so
he had a conniption fit when I reported
there were plantains other day I've just
been handed a note that Gary has a huge
bowl of plantain chips again you're
twisting the truth I did I don't care
that you reported that plantains in here
by so you go in my office and I quite
frankly don't know what you're capable
of
so I don't know when you go in my office
if you're opening drawers or looking
through [ __ ] so it's a privacy issue not
a plantain issue do you like it when I
say plantains because it's funny for you
chapter 13 the plantain issue
[Laughter]